und mein gott also das motto geiler
das ist recht hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen bio
erhalte ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
ich habe heute die wundervolle marie
dabei ist das netz wollte ja auch nicht
ja du bist auch zum ersten mal hier in
unserem neuen home studio wir haben hier
schön angerichtet tolle kulisse auf den
zuschauern gefällt sehr muss man sagen
ist wirklich höchst professionell was
wir hier abliefern will hat auch tage da
ja immer schon ein bisschen gedauert
weil es um zu dekorieren ich hoffe euch
gefällt dass wir machen heute was
krasses und zwar testen wir so richtig
satisfied products from lesen
nein alles von amazon heute nicht genau
ich finds aguilar man gar nicht lange
ich zeige euch mal das erste produkt
lasten dicken daumen nach oben
moment wir machen schon eine
chronologische reihenfolge und lasst den
dicken daumen nach oben
falls wir davon mehr platz machen sollen
und ich würde sagen let's go ich zeig
dir erst einmal das video und dann
können wir das ausprobieren damit die
zuschauer auf checken worum es geht
ok also das ist das erste produkt man
sieht hier das ist so praxisnähe das
soll so islam seien aber als also als
glasform weil es nicht mal also da sie
sonst so klar
genau das sieht dann so aus glas und du
kannst das so auseinander ziehen und so
würdest du meinen kanal abonnieren ja ja
wenn du hast du siehst also ich würde
sagen ihr habt ja jetzt gesehen
wir probieren es einfach mal aus du
kannst du gerne rein kam wo ist es denn
ja das ist es das sieht doch gut aus
leute wären wir ja nach paket
doch davon haben wir zu also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin gar nicht so
jemand ich finde das nicht immer so wie
ich ja es gibt ja gerade diesen
satisfied halb so manche also ich finde
dass der ton macht der endgeräte so gut
genau leute folgen wir auf jeden fall
auf tik tok alex klaws alex wieso ketten
das ist jetzt nicht auf irgendwie kommt
das schon so komisch das zeughaus naja
hier kann man es lesen crystal clear
intelligent knete riecht und das nicht
auf was soll das bist du musst dich
selber nicht auf gekriegt wir brauchen
ein hammer nein dort einfach messer was
du jetzt zwischen schießt mit hammer
damit dass verbiegt und wies auf machen
könnten ein gibt doch einfach mal besser
hier wäre nein wenn du abrutscht
freundchen lass es lieber was geht so
nicht
leute ich ja du kannst es raus und ich
will am anfang das führt sie echt kann
man das sieht echt aus die klasse mein
gott das ist richtig da
ich meine das andere also irgendwie das
heißt wenn man wenn wir jetzt mal hier
eine glasscheibe kaputt machen gar kein
problem die kann man hier und ausbessern
da kann man wirklich kann ich dadurch
gruppen kann man nicht ich finde so nice
fühlt sich das jetzt nicht an du schon
kann man daraus ein gutes tik tok machen
für meinen tik tok account na gut dann
machen wir das so machen
na ja gut das ist schon mal ja gut das
ist schon du bist noch nicht so der
satisfaction pro mit satisfaction kennst
du das lied das von den red hot chili
peppers rtl fiction hier nochmal marica
und du machst es so du musst halt
wirklich dass ein gefühl haben wir hohe
alter alter okay das war schon ein und
das krasse daran ist es funktioniert
auch als gummi weil ich würde sagen
interessantes produkt kann man auf jeden
fall sich können alle produkte sind
immer in der video beschreibung verlinkt
und wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
richtige weg ja es gibt schon viele
deutlich dass gekauft haben glaube ich
ich zum beispiel als nächstes haben wir
so gemälde die sich so irgendwie im
nebel vor also da die drehst du so und
dann kommt da so nebel runter nesat
muster ganz verrückt also ich kann da
'mal eins von raussuchen das zeige ich
dir mal guck mal hier
aber okay also ich hab das einfach mal
bestellt das gibt es in ganz
verschiedenen preisklassen ich habe ein
günstigeres genommen weil ich wusste
nicht ob das wirklich so nice ist du
kannst es damals so das ist so ein
gemälde irgendwie so man will ja mein
gott kommen direkt aus scheinen sind
geschichten aus fernen sind wie man hier
sehen kann es dann ein nein aus
fernsehen aber ich habe es auf jeden
fall bei amazon bestellt so machen wir
das mal auf die leute lust auf der einen
seite im spiegel
schön oder als schminktisch kann man das
gut nehmen und auf der anderen seite
aber jetzt habe ich das schon gezeigt
ist dieses amt gemeldet sagt das erstmal
den zuschauern also das sieht auch schon
wirklich sehr nice aus ersten zuschauern
ja also mich nimmt es jetzt nicht also
es ist schon schön michel und bis jetzt
nicht ganz mit lila ist eine schöne
farbe muss man sagen also guck mal hier
das hypnotisierte ja also ach so kummer
und unter diesem ganzen land sind hier
so planeten in lila also ist ein cooles
product so selbst hätte fein und dann
sieht dass hier aus kümmert das sieht
doch aus als wäre das jetzt eine welle
oder so hier oben sind auch noch so soja
wasser kügelchen oder was das sein soll
kommt manchmal kammerchor alter leute
das ist schon geil
malta hatte jetzt was auf tricks ein
boom also war das ist schon schön
das ist jetzt immer so war ganz amüsant
stunden da drin
das gefällt mir dass ich jetzt hier
nahmen mit daumen nach oben hier für
dieses produkt dann willst du ein
bisschen haider du ich finde diese
sachen testweise wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten marie ich würde sagen
ach so ja das habe ich einfach bestellt
weil es mir angezeigt wurde ich habe
keinen video dazu gesehen ich habe
einfach bei google eingegeben satisfied
produkts oder so und dann kam das bei
amazon
das ist ein bald so ein stress ball und
wenn man diesen ball drückt kommen
kugeln daraus und aus den kugeln kommen
nochmal kugeln das heißt du hast eine
kugel explosion
nein das muss so sicher ja was auf wo
mein gott und das kann halt glaube ich
nicht platzen
vielleicht ist diese alles verstehen hab
mal nein das ist meiner gekommen wenn
dir war nur einfach am alter dass also
das ist wirklich geil
einer soll eine kugel muss doch irgendwo
hier oben raus kommen wo rokkaku halter
oder mein kopf und mein gott also das
teil ja du musst mal richtig kraft haben
im finger hier follower also ich glaube
es kann nicht platzen so schnell dafür
ist das ja auch ausgelegt
das sind sogar ich weiß echt nicht
drücken das ist schlimm
diese produkte ich werde die wirklich
alle alltäglich benutzen außer die knete
verleiht wobei die eigentlich auch nicht
da haben wir gut kann man die knete uhr
das ding bei der gastronomie aus wenn
das ist nur mein wald
das ist echt geil oder kann echt nicht
platzen ich versuche auf das ist
vielleicht nicht so gut
das könnte auch so eine krankheit sein
oder das ist alkoholiker teil
das gibt mir auch mal ich hätte das
jetzt tape abgeschnitten hatte
vielleicht darf man das sogar absolut
eben das ist nicht so abschneiden das
macht doch keinen sinn da durchkommen
okay was haben wir noch darf nein das
ist der stoff muss nur die aber von
anderen parteien ich weiß ja was mit
stopps leute den staubsauger seht ihr im
nächsten party kommt man das ist das
kann man hier
da werden diese dieses booms die wir
haben haben auch so aufgeschnitten also
besser und dann macht es ja dass ich
weiß nicht und sagen ja ich habe die
aber bestellt so hier man muss es halt
einfach mal ausprobieren
dafür brauchen wir jetzt immer besser
okay leute also hier habe ich so eine
wie nennt man es eigentlich gar kannst
du diese model toni garrn weißt du warum
sie so heißt ihre mutter war eine
berühmte italienische garn spinnerin
okay du kannst du einmal kurz hier eine
aufnahme machen von dem denken wie ich
das jetzt auch machen aber ich habe
keine ahnung ob das hat funktioniert so
wie im video
das ist die 2
naja leute das war jetzt eher weniger
man aber ich habe noch einen macht
morgen da geht es um zuckerwatte es auch
es muss aber dafür zuckerwatte kaufen
doch nicht das weiß auch spontan was wir
das schon gedreht haben muss ich sagen
leute wir sehen uns morgen wieder da
gibt es noch eine party von aber danke
dass du schon mal dabei was ich brauche
dich noch für some great leute was geht
ab wir haben schon den nächsten tag
maries leider weg ich habe soeben
angekündigt heute checken wir einer
dieser ball nimmt man den hab ich den
ganzen tag in der hand heute schicken
wir das konnten kennen die experiment ab
auch super set ist fein nicht zeigen
euch mal kurz im videoclip wirklich nice
also leider habe ich jetzt nicht so viel
zucker wie im video
aber das kann man sich auf jeden fall
gut geben ok also hier ist halt sondern
mutter mit ihrem kind ich weiß nicht wie
man so ne fette zuckerwatte hinkriegt
aber es sieht halt schon genial aus und
diese zuckerwatte verfliegt halt
praktisch in diesem wasser
ich habe auch videos gesehen da sieht es
so aus also da zieht sich das wasser so
nach oben rein
falls man das verstehen kann und die
zuckerwatte verschwindet so einfach in
der luft das will ich auch mal
ausprobieren deswegen habe ich auch zwei
gekauft also das ist schon krass und das
wasser färbt sich dann halt einfach so
dunkel ist wird so brot und dann halt
voll schwarz und jetzt trinken trinken
muss ich das jetzt nicht unbedingt muss
ich sagen ich war gerade einkaufen ich
dachte eigentlich es gibt keine zu
karate in diesem laden so eine große
einkaufsladen sogar der verkäufer hat
gesagt sogar fatal wenn ich da habe ich
ganz unten im regal ganz in der ecke
noch so drei packungen gefunden und mit
zwei mitgenommen
früher auf der kirmes immer zuckerwatte
die kann man ja auch so ein bisschen
ziehen oder da kann man nicht nein jetzt
tue ich dir hier ins wasser kann man
hier durch gucken was auch ich bin mal
gespannt ob das wirklich so nice
aussieht wo walter kummer hat gesehen
hatte du nimmst du gehst hier rein und
das verpufft halt wirklich in der luft
sieht es aus wie eine qualle oder so ok
einmal das schon angenehm
man konnte das könnte man da könnte man
sich dran gewöhnen sag ich mal so eine
haben ob es gab leider nur diese pinken
unicorn dinger so einmal rein hier unten
halten wir die ganzen geht es ganz weg
wenn ich glaube nicht und doch knapp und
das letzte ist noch für mich ziemlich
zucker intensiv ich würde sagen hiermit
kann man das ja eigentlich gut
abschließen also dass zuckerwatte
experiment hat mich jetzt auch noch mal
sehr wie sagt man satisfied wie auch
immer keine ahnung ich weiß noch nicht
mal wichtig wieder nennen werde auf
jeden fall wenn er sagt leute mache auf
jeden fall den zweiten part gerne wieder
mit marie lassen noch nach oben da
schreibt sie in die kommentare und
abonniert auf jeden fall auch den kanal
gerne könnt ihr mir videos schicken dich
dann ausprobieren soll irgendwelche
produkte die ich bestellen muss was weiß
ich ansonsten habe ich euch alles in der
video beschreibung verlinken check das
gerne ab und wir sehen uns dann ich weiß
nicht wann wir uns wiedersehen auf jeden
fall sehr dabei ich denke den nächsten
zwei tagen weil ich mich jetzt hier ein
bisschen mehr auf kohlen content
konzentrieren möchte wirklich noch das
machen möchte was nice es noch mehr mühe
die videos stecken will
und ich hoffe ihr habt spaß dran
abonnieren das war's mir haut rein